来咱们是不是应该放的音乐挺吧 算了不是不放音乐了
我好像放音乐不好 还是这样
这不是放音乐不好 玩了好
对 下点来的 下点是吧
怎么办呢 今晚大家聊
怎么
跟座飞机呀
好 黄健 黄健 黄健 黄健来了
新年长呀 今天讲的一个
如何给亚公司公司
放在音乐器呢 放在音乐器可以
放在音乐器
一会儿我还怎么路的什么呢
我看啊
我有没有
有没有
不行
没有音乐
今天聊怎么呼持
今天聊怎么给一家公司公司
别放了
不放了
做事
我看啊 我准备一下
这本书
好看 这本书行行
这本书也好 这本书
这本书也可以
嗯
报道了
好
我没看聊
是谁 老火箭 老火器
还要我是焦焦
今天 晚上好 晚上好
晚上好
最近 最近好书不少
对不起
也可能是说我今天的心情肯定很好
为什么你
为什么呢
可以见的人
为什么要听
谁说我要听
为好了吗
对了 我好像忘了这个什么了
今天还在路上
中心的小伙伴
我看我查一下
这个是哪一个
赚钱 那什么
光扶大长
还很正常
所以一场一正常
我的那个
中窗的多大长
还是
还真就是
最近我中窗的全都大长
然后基本上中窗是
你们也都知道
你们也都看着了
开始政体吧
没有我们一般要等一下
等到这个八点十分
有还有小伙
还有很多小伙
小伙伴在那个路上
嗯
温底
你若按好辩子芯片
你好
嗯
哪几个
你看
你们现在在淘论上升通道
已经开启
可是前两天
下跌的时候你没有加藏吗
嗯
对
前两天在一个
下跌的时候
你有没有加藏啊
还是下跑了
哈哈
放手过来听听
我这个
我这边还真就没得啥
我那个手机在外边
我的手机在外边
今天今天分享什么呀
今天分享一些
这个今天分享什么故事
嗯
对
我我们很多老婆
你在这儿知道
我差不多
1月份就清除了很多
很多很多那个
很多钱
然后在
前一段时间
这个开始下跌的时候
我早上去一半
所以呢
虽然不多吧
对
就静静静
静静光府来说
那差不多我基本上
长得百分之
多少我还没看
我不知道长得多少
百分多少
六十多
我不是
六十五六十七
七十
现在是八十
没有多少
我们是十几吧
我们是十几
新租怎么样了
新租啊
新租重写啊
新租重写了
你没看吗
我现在刚才写这个
我现在那还写
被动租一张
一个一张看
好像进向啊
百分之二是
百分之二是差不多
还有另外一个就是
规料
规料那个长得也挺多
所以差不多
百分之十几百分之二是吧
基本上是
对啊
光府的话
下来我差不多是半艙
有从下跌的时候
开什么
就是这百到现在
我不是会本上
差不多就是
这段时间
长得百分之十几二是
看
就是我最近在宠写
什么呢
被动租会逼换
那么
我们之前一直快点
讲基础逼换
怎么越多怎么思考
然后其实现在我开始
从写的是
被动租会逼换
这个位置
然后
关于
原来有一张叫
你一定要投资
伤了不写了
对吧
既然你都看得也输了
我还写你
一定要投资干嘛的
没有意义
一些基本长社会
干掉了
我把它放在下面的简直
看了
看了一部分
十几岁掉了
我把十几岁掉了
怎么越多才报岁掉了
我觉得这基本工
就不讲了
然后
删了五张
从理的意义下
就是投资本质
然后最简单的投资
最简单投资是什么样子
然后
孤算母要东西的价值
然后怎么就吃别家
红丝
然后怎么发现的行为
这个
用路上来写这个部分吧
现在的话呢
就是从写
投资本质放开了
然后怎么去孤职
我如果不出意外的话
今天晚上我会在
社群里面放出一部分
就是
先放出一个六十分的版本
就像投资本质一样
投资本质是最初
我写完了以后
我认为六十分放开了
中间翻乱夫妇改得很多变
就社群需要玩得看到
就是我之前一遍
后来又改了一遍
现在投资本质
我差不多个人
认为可以做到八十分的
投资本质在一部分
然后孤算的这个部分的话
我可能
今天买了放出来
今天买应该会放出来
然后可能还会在改
今天中心
中心
这个
给我推荐过基本上
书记过来了
一个是相帅的
以前写的书
相帅以前
叫什么呢
不叫相帅
叫相帅无花
后来改名叫相帅
这个
今天有五面
今天刚忘
中心给我
记过来了
我没看
我没看一看怎么样
如果不错的话
然后我们就
我就把它上心
因为这样的天
是太忙了
太多了
所以我没看
另外的话
中心给我推荐了
基本上关于世界的中心
就是包括普京
包括世界中心
包括这次危机的一些很早
很就是的一些格局的一些
那种我大概少了一项
八个书窗里的
这两个还没看
看来以后
分析上给大家
所以大家如果对现在
大家现在如果对
现在局势